I heard and you tell me if this is true
that your character on the show Jarrell
has become so popular there are now
professional impersonators is that right
you can you can get like a darryl for a
party is that right
well a friend of mine was at a hotel and
this guy was sitting at the bar and he
had the same baseball hat i wear on the
same clothes i have on in the same
haircut and the same boots and my friend
goes you look like my friend Norman he
goes yeah I played Norman Reedus
he goes oh you you dressed as Daryl
Dixon he goes I do that on the weekends
but on the weekdays I play Norman Reedus
and had a business card and it gets
creepy I mean it like we're gonna feasts
like writing checks in your name and
what if he's who knows what he's doing I
think he's getting laid so things are
going well for you - that's good I mean
if the guy is the guy doing but it'd be
a shame if he was doing better than you
yeah I think he probably is you know
he's not getting laid the Conan
impersonator what's the problem
ladies I'm really him
you